hi I'm Libby I'm 24 and I'm from friends
and to be hung inside of the box I don't
pretend to be a screenwriter and yet I I
right since since quite a while now and
the reason for that is am an impotent
filmic hurry and obviously you can find
your own material also I would add that
well I would have quite a lot stories in
mind so you know I tried to work with
people and you give up his ideas and
products and Indians I write it so for
me it all started was with this simple
child book but Steven Spielberg and
after reading it I from is for my parent
camcorder and I never stopped filming
and then in high school I got the chance
to meet with treatment visor who also
he's a screenwriter but for comic books
so he helped us to put together clubs in
a mine that really got me more into into
filmmaking but then coming in university
I didn't study cinema at physics because
I was the safe part of the plan and well
I still at the Edit moments I had less
means to shoot so I wrote more so again
even though i don't really different
myself as a screenwriter I guess I can I
am since I spin right when I finished
with all that I thought I should give it
a chance of my passion because well this
is my pleasure I visited so with the
friends we slide the same project that
was completely in a sense it all came
from the the fact that we we had to test
for my job I had to test ddg I runnin
and so it shatters it was in the forest
so kind of wore sequins and and we
thought where could that happen at the
moment maybe you crying that was a
confession Ukraine and from that we
invented the spy action movie we're in
and we try to found the evidence or if
I'm like reasonable explanation for
everything to draw a very complex
background with that and device first we
just had an idea when we try to see how
far we could go with bell in no means at
all so I just propose you to watch what
we did we spelled a two-thousand-dollar
well my Informer told me that there will
be a poker game so Alexa would be there
a bad contact with David and
so I hope you enjoyed it and now hourly
I tried to answer your question because
you know I got carried away introduction
dawn hello long even screenwriter well
forever obviously telling have you been
working on the script so yeah this
product started in last January last
January February and at first we just
really focused on writing the first 30
minutes to see where we could go that
was doable part with not too much action
or special effects or explosion or you
know choppers whatever and then since
the result was pretty good i started
working hard on the scrapes in last
November november december a bit of
january and about the tremendous i came
with this first draft so yes I'm a
filmmaker and yet I bet that's why crew
why do i do right and after talking with
few friends especially one who's a
natural screenwriter he advised me
obviously to revise his draft and
perhaps to improve the motivation the
risk that the dt emphasize the risk that
the character I taking obviously that's
that's missing in this version so it's
still working progress but it's the
whole idea is about one year old so
pretty young for a project obviously why
did you write it well again that's
coming in on with the story I just told
you it's it's more the kind of thing
that happen to us as much as we decided
to do it about when do I rights mostly
um alone or at night because I'm a
fellow at night so yeah I prefer to be
alone and about what I'm talking that's
a tough question i guess i would say
perhaps patients also not like you know
personal scale but to be patient to wait
for inspiration to come or to go out and
find your own way to inspire yourself so
grabs me patience why haven't you
written the script I read like this
question actually for me it's it's right
now it's some my passion sort of all the
flag for its what i stand four so no i
won't quit on that so i don't know
there's some more crowdfunding campaign
and people actually supported that so I
can't quit I've committed to myself into
people so I want with that's just you
know and then tell us a story about your
screen writing career I don't have a
career yet and perhaps you could help me
with that so you know I rely on you for
that one now you might be wondering but
how are going to interview this french
guy in the same process of developing
this project I got a contact in a who
offered me to come visit and perhaps
connect with you people so i'll be in LA
in april so voila now I thanks for
watching I hope you enjoyed it and
before leaving you on add some more
material of what we shot this soon
hopefully see you bye shut up Tony but
go home let's get him David
maybe that's why timely only two
kidnapped
you two are close right
Benji damoclarke on yeah
impress me
you are